allez maintenant on va partir chez nos
voisins belges alors là c'est une
histoire assez incroyable
ils ont ils ont le chic pour ça il ya un
détenu qui a réussi à s'évader en
profitant de l'inattention des gardiens
vous allez voir franchement c'est
collector on a vu ça dans le rose aping
de france info une évasion rocambolesque
en belgique alors qu'il était en charge
du nettoyage des entrées de la prison ce
détenu de 39 ans a tout simplement
attendu que la porte s'ouvre pour sortir
les gardiens n'ont rien vu et il semble
qu'hier ils aient profité d'un moment
d'inattention pour s'enfuir l'homme
purgeait une peine de cinq ans pour vol
avec violence
la police ne lui a toujours pas retrouvé
alors depuis le sujet ça y est il a été
interpellé on l'a récupéré ils étaient
tranquilles chez un membre de sa famille
oga faire si vous me cherchez je suis à
la maison il est il était il avait
quitté la prison afin je le cite de
poivre et légumes et d'éclaircir un
problème familial
problème réglé ils auraient raison de
son prix il aurait raison de leur écorce
de frimer baver autant lui donner les
clés pour sortir directement le nec est
en charge de l'entrée et la sortie il
est à un mètre d'une porte
qu'est ce qui peut bien faire j'ai tenté
un plan c qui sait faire l'accent belge
ici non c'est que j'ai fait un peu le
badge ou g d'ogive suis belge et
portugaise ah oui c'est le mélange non
je peux pas faire mes origines d'alger
vrai qu'il a eu raison de s'évader parce
que contrairement à l'or il a eu raison
que celle de pascal rambert logique en
fait l'évasion n'est pas punissable par
la loi sauf si celui de délits par
exemple si vous vous aider et vous
braquez quelqu'un ensuite vous bousculez
quelqu'un là dans ce cas là vous allez
être condamné pour le délit qui suit
l'évasion mais l'évasion en elle-même
elle n'est pas à l'abri sable pendant
que là par exemple il avait pris cinq
ans on l'a récupéré il fera ses cinq ans
relance s'il n'a pas menacé un gardien
s'il n'a pas bousculé une vieille dame
sur le trottoir dans ce cas là il
indique donc du coup effectivement ça se
tente
vous en pensez tient avec le hashtag
c'est que des lt ce prisonnier belge qui
est partie tranquille où bill ou allez
hop par la porte d'entrée nous donc
tranquille obligatoire sur 2019
voilà c'est pas sûr